another active learning technique that
can be very very effective in supporting
student learning is the jigsaw and it
gets its name from the from the the
activity involved when you do a jigsaw
puzzle and usually most people when they
do a jigsaw will look for the the board
they'll find all the edge pieces or
they'll find all the blue pieces or
they'll find all the pieces that have
have a certain image on them you do the
homogeneous aspects of the exercise so
you get all the edge pieces the blue
pieces the the particular image pieces
but eventually you have to take those
pieces and put them together you have to
link them up with pieces that don't look
quite like those pieces so that's the
heterogeneous component of it and and so
what you do in a jigsaw is you ask
students to become experts if you will
homogeneous experts in a particular area
on a particular topic and you can do
this by giving them a reading in class
well you can do this by asking to
reflect on something that you've you've
addressed in in a previous class or that
they've addressed in a previous homework
but but they sit together or they
collect they they group together in this
what I call homogeneous group where
everyone is talking about the same
particular topic and they just discuss
that topic and they become experts in
that homogeneous topic and then you can
have three or four different topics
whatever depending on the sizes size of
the class and you have these local
groups of experts like the edge pieces
and the blue pieces and them and the
picture pieces and then after giving
them a period of time maybe five minutes
ten minutes depending on the class you
break them up into heterogeneous groups
so you get one one representative from
Group A goes with one representative
from Group B and one representative come
from C and one representative from Group
D and now you have a new heterogeneous
group that has an A or B a C and D in it
or if we use the puzzle analogy you have
a group that has some person that's the
edge expert some persons that's the
picture expert in some person that's the
blue piece expert
and they're all in a group and now they
share what they know individually with
each other and then they combine that
expertise they synthesize that expertise
to make something bigger to come up with
a global under understanding of the
problem and then each group does that in
their own way so the heterogeneous
groups then form a more holistic or a
more heterogeneous solution to the
problem as if they're putting together
the different kinds of puzzle pieces and
then again as with the other activities
we ask them to to then report out before
that I usually ask I usually will
circulate in the room the same way I do
with the pair share to hear what each of
the groups are saying to see if any
groups are having particular issues or
if they have some particular
breakthroughs that I want to make sure
they share with with the class as a
whole there's some logistical issues one
you want to make sure that the students
really can become these homogeneous
experts so if you have a group of four
people that they've all really come up
to speed on the topic so ideally you
would give a pre class assignment and
you'd say yes I need everybody to read
this article and to be able to explain
this point this point in this point and
you would find that - that group that a
particular group of students and then
you do the same with a few other topics
you you're assuming then that the
students have read the paper or Rett
have read the article whatever it is you
want them to read and that they
understand it to the level that you hope
they understood it sometimes you don't
have time for that or it just doesn't
work out so you give them something to
read within in class and again that can
be tricky students may not have the same
level of understanding so groups may be
a little bit spotty the other thing that
can happen with the jigsaw which is like
a really silly problem but it but
sometimes it just trips you up is if you
have depending on a number of students
you have to kind of think on your feet
about how many students are in the
homogeneous group versus how many
students are in the heterogeneous group
if it's a perfect square it works fine
so if you've got nine students or
sixteen students or or twenty-five
students you know you have five groups
of five groups in one situation than
five groups in the other that means you
have to have the same number of groups
as heterogeneous topics so if I went
ABCD I have to then have four groups
because I had to have four A's for B's
for season four DS so sometimes just the
number of topics and the number of
students that you have in your class
makes it kind of hard to make groups
that don't have extra people or aren't
short a particular expert and that's
just something you want to plan
beforehand and if somebody doesn't come
to class you know if you know you have
25 students in your class and someone
doesn't show up then you have to kind of
deal with it on this on the fly but that
can be the biggest that can be the
trickiest thing when the jigsaw is just
getting the number students right